when you talked to your parents and told
them I'm making this movie about my
experience your parents are played by
Holly Hunter Ray Romano terrific actors
doing great job what was that like for
your parents to know that okay these are
the actors playing I mean I called them
every step of the way you make phone
calls to like breathe new some had a new
thing that's happening hey we're making
a movie about this hey there were people
playing you hey and raising Arizona's
like my family's movie so she was very
excited but the first Holly Hunter
obviously in that movie whatever role
like her first big role yeah this first
thing my mom said was well Holly Hunter
is prettier than me but your husband my
dad said Holly Hunter is prettier than
me but your father is more handsome than
Ray Romano yeah so sweet that's so sweet
I made the mistake of telling that to
Camille I told ray immediate Ram Romano
but every QA we did ever would bring it
up say that exact quote over and over
again set it at the premiere said it to
my parents to their faces and then shook
my dad's at hand and said you know what
you are more handsome than me everybody
loves them yeah yeah it's Raymond they
all look something confused and I'm not
Conan
you